hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be covering from round four
of this year's fide World Cup it is
Vincent kaimer vs Magnus Carlsen it's a
very important game for both of them
obviously as they want to qualify for
the candidates maybe Magnus not so much
but Vincent definitely wouldn't mind and
also Vincent has never defeated Magnus
Carlsen In classical chess uh so let's
dive straight into it and see what
happened here it's quite a brutal game
you guys will have to awesome pause the
video moments uh to get here Vincent
like Magnus was seated directly into
round two as he was in the top 50
participants of the video World Cup uh
he defeated Daniel Darby and I'm in
Tabata by at the Retron 4 and the Magnus
of course defeated 11 once lie and
aryantari in rounds to number three also
was seated directly into round two so
that being said let's check it out quite
a lot to enjoy here and I'm gonna try to
spoil as little as possible uh during
the analysis we have pawned the D4 by
Vincent and the Magnus goes for Knight
to F6 with C4 E6 Knight to C3 and now
Pawn to D5 not going for anything crazy
like a nimso Indian uh C captures e
characters and now Bishop to G5 although
it's not uh unreasonable to expect
Magnus to go for a Nims of Indian Right
In classical against a player like
Vincent so okay Bishop to B4 uh we have
Pawn to E3 and now Ponte H6 challenging
the bishop and G5 Bishop to F4 and now
Bishop to F5 we have Bishop to D3
countering the bishop on on F5 and here
we have Bishop characters and queen
captures and here Vincent knows this
game incredibly well because he already
lost this position uh he had last year
and he lost it in the wheelchairs
Festival against none other than go cash
but here they continue a different path
in that game uh castles was played but
here we have pawned the C6 so it is now
a different game uh but uh uh yeah and
it is now as of move nine that we have a
completely new game so Magnus chooses a
different route how to save Magnus knows
this game that was played as bookish did
win it so obviously he played very well
so maybe Magnus knows even better so
okay Pawn to C6 with Knight T2 now
getting ready to Castle and Knight the
H5 Magnus now goes after the bishop on
F4 Bishop to E5 puts pressure on the G7
pawn and Knight to D7 goes after
uh Vincent's Bishop on E5 Ponte H3 and
now just Knight H back to F6 uh with
Bishop back to eat H2 you could capture
it but of course Magnus has a different
plans and he knows what he's doing we
have castles and now there are sorry
castles uh and now Pawn to A3 chasing
away the bishop and Bishop to A5 with uh
castles finally and Rook to E8 we have
Rook 8 to C1 and Magnus goes Queen to E7
develops the queen connects the Rooks
and now Pawn to B4 of course uh Bishop
back to d8 and now Knights the G3 so a
bit of a weird Square for the bishop but
the bishop now Returns the C7 uh we have
Knight to F5 and now Bishop captures an
H2 we have King characters and queen to
E6 now pulling pressure on the Knight
here so the Knight goes back Knight to
G3 and queen to D6 now pinning the uh
the Knight here King back to G1 and now
Pawn to A5 going after Vincent's B Pawn
and this is where things start to get a
very very interesting Vincent plays
Queen back to B1 he wants to put
pressure along the B file and now Knight
the B6 uh we have eight B captors and A5
I Vincent did consider some moves here
because you you don't have the capture
it's not a forced capture you could also
consider something like E4 here but it
is
um you know if if it brings you
Advantage then it's great if it doesn't
then maybe hold off with it so instead B
captures an A5 and now Knight the C4
Magnus now wants to recapture with the
Rook uh we have Queen to B4 Vincent
offers a queen trade so of course you're
not gonna trade because then he captures
some B4 guards the A5 Pawn so Rook
captures an A5 and uh here comes the
fireworks Knight captures on D5 so what
can you do here it's a very uh a very
cool move because you can recapture
three different ways you could play C
characters Queen characters and The Rook
captures and only one uh one one
recapture is basically good because if
you play C characters on D5 then Rook
captures and C4 removes the defender of
The Rook on A5 you're gonna have to
trade Queens Queen captures on B4 and
now Rook characters on B4 and okay the
game continues equal material
uh and that equal material white will be
up upon so maybe try to avoid this after
Knight captures on D5 Queen captures on
D5 is also possible but then again Rook
captures in C4 Rook captures on A3 a
nice fishing sug uh Queen characters and
A3 Queen captures on C4 and LK Rook to
B1 will put pressure on the B Pawn uh
you're gonna play Pawn to B5 and okay
equal material uh you know a fine game
for both and not uh maybe even a bad one
you do have a past B Pawn however Magnus
decides to go for the absolute best line
and that is Knight captures on D4 and D5
because you also will get uh a lot a lot
without actually giving much so Queen
captures on C4 and now Rook captures an
A3 now it's a fine position Vincent
doing incredibly well however he is
spending a lot more time than Magnus
he's down to 15 minutes and the clock
and Magnus has almost an hour some 56
minutes on the clock it's okay Queen to
C5 the Vincent boldly offers a queen he
challenges the the final boss of the end
game to a duel and the Magnus accepts
Queen captures and C5 and Rook captures
on C5 we have Rook um uh 88 now doubling
up on the a file now you can put the
Rook on the second rank you can put the
Rook on B2 to help you advance the the B
Pawn if you can defend your C6 Pawn
somehow also you can play Rook day one
you can uh trailer Rook so magnus's
position is very good here uh Knight the
F5 and here we have Pawn to H5 Magnus of
course wants to kick away the Knight but
he doesn't want to allow Knight captures
on H6 so he first plays this and this
also fights against Vincent's next move
which is spawn to G4 uh Vincent still
plays it and he plays it with 10 minutes
on the uh on the clock and this is only
move 31 you have to reach move 40 in
order to reach uh uh time control and be
awarded additional time so H characters
and G4 we have H captors and now Rook to
A2 nicely putting the Rook on the on the
second rank uh also you have to be a
little bit careful if the Knight moves
and lets you put a king on the second
rank you have to worry about some like
Knight characters on E3 if the F Pawn
will be pinned so it's a very nasty
Square for The Rook uh and here we have
a Rook to B1 putting pressure on the B7
Pawn here Rook day one Magnus trades of
a pair of Rooks with Rook captures and
Rook captures an A1 with check with King
to G2 and now King to f8 Magnus also
starts activating his King and here
Vincent plays Pawn to G5 and it's such a
such a tricky position uh uh but again
the problem is uh Vincent is very very
low on time four more moves need to be
made to reach time control Vincent has
four minutes and the clock Magnus has 50
minutes on the clock and here Magnus did
something that you should never do in an
end game he started playing against not
the position itself but against his
opponent's time and Magnus blunders a
move he plays Knight to C7
and it's a very uh normal looking movie
you want to play Knights day six and of
course attack The Rook ended up the pawn
uh on on G5 but this uh is actually
already completely lost if Vincent can
punish this Knight to C7 move and play a
perfect game for the rest of the game
against Magnus Carlsen so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find
this idea while I give you a couple of
seconds
yeah
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on being a true
Master of the end game and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is night to day six that's the move that
uh that stops magnus's idea because now
his plan of Knight to the E6 will be
punished uh severely if he goes Knight
to E6 look at this Rook to F5 now still
defends the pawn but also puts pressure
on the F7 pawn and now Knight d8
defending the pawn is met with G6 of
course you cannot allow the capture
You're Gonna Play F6 and now look at
this Rook the H5 now threatening Rook
DHA check Fall by Knight the F5 with
checks so you're gonna move the Knight
96 Rook the h8 with Chuck King to E7 and
now Knight to F5 with the check King to
D7 and now the final uh strike Knight
captures on G7 Knight captures Rook H7
will uh take the Knight out and you will
uh have this position being up upon but
also having a pass the Jeep on already
on G6 let's say King D6 Rook captures
here you're threatening the pawn but
there's there's also very little black
can do against the past Jeep when you're
just going to move the rook and Advance
your Pawn to Victory uh black can put
some resistance here but all in all it
is very much winning for Vincent so
Magnus has to find a different way after
Knight these six Magnus plays G6 but now
uh there's a different uh approach here
uh also okay you could try something
like Rook the B1 if you're wondering
what happens here just Rook F5 I mean
that's all there is to it the the pawn
is being a threatened there's you know
in a way to defend it if you move at
Knight captures an F7 if you attack The
Rook Pawn to E4 it defends the rook and
again you're gonna be up a pawn so
instead after 96 like I said Pawn to G6
by Magnus and now comes uh Knight
capture some B7 you cannot defend
everything so he had to give up a pawn
Rook B1 and now Knight to d8
uh going after the C6 Pawn as well Rook
the B5 and now Rook captures on B5 this
is much better than just going after the
pawn here and then after Pawn captures
Knight A6 and you cannot defend the the
C5 Pawn so it's better to keep the pawns
together Rook capture some B5 Pawn
characters and now Knight to C6 and now
uh Magnus has to figure out how to how
to try and hold this because it's not
gonna be easy not only is Magnus down
upon but Vincent will have the full
Center once those pawns come to D4 E4
and F4 he will have control over all of
the all all over all of the board
basically so King to E8 we have Knight
to the B4 King the E7 and now Pawn to F4
we have King to D6 and now King to F3 we
have knighted the E6 now trying to
create some weaknesses here of course if
the pawn is pushed then D4 and F4 will
be a little bit weak but Vincent not in
a rush to do this King Day 2 is played
and now Knight to G7 again uh uh Vincent
is burning quite a lot of time he's
again again down to 15 minutes on the
clock even though additional time has
been awarded to him so he has to be very
very careful how do you continue here
well Vincent played Ponte E4 and it is
the absolute best move uh it's uh hard
to say what Magnus had in mind here uh
well it's not very hard because we know
what he played but basically if you play
something like Knight E6 attack the
pawns then just King E3 and they are
defended so Magnus went Knight to H5
instead now king of three and now Magnus
just goes back Knight to G7 this is
basically saying okay I know I'm lost I
can just wait until you give me
something to you know sink my teeth in
so Knights the D3 by Vincent and now
Knight back to H5 and here King the E3
uh if you play something like Ponte if I
would check then King D5 and it's a draw
your opponent D4 Pawn is hanging King D3
King C4 now we're gonna start advancing
the pawn this is not for Magnus to draw
the game so after this King the E3 was
played and also notice that D5 here will
be met with this very very tricky and
this was kind of the idea behind
magnus's Knight to H5 Pawn to F6 or Pawn
to F5 for that matter point is that
after G6 and Knight captures Magnus uh
would probably sacrifice a piece here
King characters spawn captures and now
King to E6 and this is now a draw
Knights the b14 captures and now the
Knight is stuck here guarding against
the past B Pawn and the king is stuck
here guarding the F Pawn and there are
even some variations where white can
actually lose this position so that's
why after Knight H5 we have King to E3
by Vincent a very long time but playing
uh engine precise moves with knights the
G3 and now only Now Pawn to D5 we have
King to C7 by Magnus and King to D4 we
have King to B6 uh eight minutes eight
minutes is now what Vincent has to
believe in himself and if they're like
everyone said if this was anyone else
sitting across wins and he would just
blast through the position but as it is
well arguably one of the greatest if not
the greatest player ever to play the end
game uh you know in chess in general
sitting uh across him you know you have
to be a little bit careful and he goes
Knight to E5 King E5 is also winning but
it's a it's a very tricky line I would
just show it because it's super fun
Knight to E2 now I have to be again very
careful uh idea for Pawn could hang and
also Knight the D4 check in some lines
could be irrelevant King F6 Now Pawn to
B4 D6 now you're gonna block the pawn
and now King to E7 of course now you
have to help out with the Knight Knight
the D4 D7 Knights the E6 you stop
promotion but now Knight captures on B4
and with the elimination of the past
b-pawn Black's chances of a draw are
very much gone King C5 You're Gonna Play
E5 you can even sacrifice the Knight
here captures captures and now you're
gonna win all of the pawns knightless
here King captures here and you have
four points against the Knight of course
completely winning for Vincent but he
doesn't want to risk anything he's down
uh to a few minutes and um well you just
don't want to overthink at night they 5
also looks very much winning and now
Magnus plays Pawn to B4 very often a uh
a winning move in in any position Knight
captures on F7 and now Pawn to B3 and
now Magnus did uh well everything and
all he could do there is um only one
move for Vincent here that wins the game
and it's not an easy one to spot feel
free to pause the video and try to beat
Magnus Carlsen in an end game while I
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on being once
again a true Master of the end game and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is Knight to E5 this is the
only move that wins and yes it's very
hard to uh you know fight the urge to
just push pawns but uh to give you an
example if Ponte D6 King to C6 and now
if King to C3 you have to stop the fast
Pawn Knight captures an E4 check King
captures on B3 Knight captures on D6 and
that's it yes white is up upon but it is
not enough to win the game and another
thing if you don't go Knight to E5 you
might uh try Knight to D6 but now look
at this 92 check goes after the F4 Pawn
you defend it now King C5 goes after the
Knight and you cannot trade Knights
because it's a draw and if Knight B7
check you just follow the Knight Knights
to the uh six checking to C5 just follow
the White Knight and there is no no win
here but Vinton finds it he plays Knight
to E5 with some two minutes on the clock
and he really slammed that Knight into
the center of the board and once Magnus
saw this he he knew that it was over
Knight
check was played King to E3 and now King
the B5 even if Ponte B2 of course
Knights the C4 check picks up the pawn
nicely with a fork so also something
that doesn't really work in magnus's
favor he played King to B5 now he is
threatening B2 if Vincent allows it then
he he loses the game but he finds a very
nice Knight to D3 and with the Knight on
D3 guarding the B2 Square there is no
crossing the B2 Square Knights the C3
was played with Fanta D6 now comes King
to C6 and Ponte E5 and here Magnus
looked at this move for a few seconds he
made a very sad face not a very sad face
but like maybe
you know I can't even make that face
it's like it's it's the face of true
sadness you can't just make that up if
if you're not like a great actor or
something which I'm not uh and yeah it
was in this position and move 58 that
Magnus Carlsen resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
Vincent takes Magnus Down In classical
for the first time in his life and now
he's very very close to actually uh
knocking Magnus out of the feeder World
Cup which would be uh brilliant for for
Vincent but it would be a horror for
Magnus as he uh really wants to win this
it is basically the only chess
tournament he never won like I said
aside from the official random which
kind of isn't actual chess but you know
uh you know if you call that chess then
I guess there are two tournaments uh and
yeah uh there's no time to celebrate
Vincent has to prepare very very uh much
of for next game he will have black
against Magnus Carlsen and Magnus will
play this very very slowly he will you
know crunch all the numbers he he will
squeeze every position and he will try
to equalize and force Ty breaks against
Vincent but of course if Vincent can get
a draw then it's gonna be a very very
sad day for Magnus but Vincent with a
chance to go go further go to the final
16 and maybe win a chance at qualifying
for the feed a candidates tournament and
then maybe even a chance to become a
world champion so there's really a lot
at stake here for Vincent
uh here you resign because there's
really no hope if you try let's unite
the D1 checking to D2 and even if you
try this tricky B2 move or to try and
win then I just King the seat you can
just ignore this doesn't really matter
King C2 and that's it you are without a
move you can promote to a queen uh and
that's it Knight D3 but there is no you
cannot touch the base of the pawn chain
the Knight defends it that means you
can't touch any of the pawns you can't
push this Pawn uh you're just gonna you
know make moves uh for no good reason
and of course Magnus will not to do this
to his opponent as he's a true gentleman
uh so yeah that's the game really hope
you guys enjoy the brilliant stuff by
Vincent hope you guys solved that one
but both pause the video moments and
what can I say they both involved
Knights Knights are tricky bastards if
you if you can Master the Knight then
you've mastered chess truly uh so yeah
once again really hope you guys enjoyed
it I would like to thank um Erin is the
best wife no Laura is the best wife
Corrine is the best wife in the entire
universe period Jacqueline best wife in
all parallel universes has entered the
chat and actually hadel is the best wife
obviously for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of This
Magnificent event until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day